so the Terminator is one of those films
that I think changed Cinema a classic of
the genre made many people's careers and
turned several of the cast members into
household names everything about it is
incredible and throughout this video I
want to break down the entire film scene
by scene to talk about why it works so
well this video is packed with Easter
eggs hidden details and a lot of things
I haven't seen pointed out before so I
hope you enjoy watching it as much as
I've enjoyed making it now though I
normally start off these videos by
diving right into it I actually want to
start by discussing where James Cameron
was at before he made this movie Cameron
was slowly scratching an email for
himself in Hollywood and this caught the
attention of the people running the show
at piranha too broad on is a special
effects supervisor he ended up replacing
the original director after he was fired
from the production this guide being let
go of a creative differences and
unfortunately Cameron ran into the same
issues when he was working on the set
having to direct with an English to
Italian dictionary he found himself
given no credit control over anything
and eventually he was let go as well
however his name was kept on the picture
as a director even though he actually
didn't do much of it and had no say over
the final edit this is something he'd
come to hate and later never saw has
made a brilliant breakdown going over
all the making of stuff that you should
definitely check out after this
massively help with the research here
and learning about the whole crazy story
that happened with Cameron on set the
first bit of this video has been kind of
cripped from that but it's about 58
minutes long and will never get to the
movie If I just repeat that guy's work
so yeah go check that out if you want to
learn more about the ins and outs of
what went on on set and I have to bring
it up because it kind of leads into the
Terminator itself now upon leaving
Piranha 2 Cameron said he found the
entire experience extremely demoralizing
completely exhausted he ended up
crashing out in a motel and it said in
the night he had a fateful fever dream
that would change everything in the
vision camera and soul metallic skeleton
rising out the fire covered in human
skin and it crawled across the floor
coming directly for him Cameron woke up
with ideas racing through his head and
as they say the rest is history now he
did eventually sketch what he saw in his
vision and this is available online or
we've got it on screen right now the
whole thing looks absolutely terrifying
and that takes us into the first thing
that I want to go over that is The
Terminator itself and White's iconic
design has lasted for so long metallic
skeleton is arguably one of the most
infamous images in pop culture and from
the second you see it it's something
that sticks with you I think what's so
striking about it is that we can see how
it's based on us but due to the metallic
structure we're unable to connect with
it there's something almost alien about
it and this cold and feeling robot is
missing what makes us us oh there they
do have human body parts in the design
and if you look at the teeth then you'll
notice that they're real that's
something that always stuck out to me
and the machines have this because it's
one of the only things under the
endoskeleton that someone will be able
to see thus they'd have to be real in
order to throw people off but it's so
unnerving thinking about what Skynet
would have had to do in order to get
these teeth now there's also the iconic
red eyes too which peers through the
skull when it's damaged and that half
man half Machine Head is almost
Unforgettable at the face of the
Terminator is very iconic too and that's
of course provided by Arnold
Schwarzenegger who built his brand off
the back of this role however it wasn't
always gonna be like that and originally
Cameron wanted Lance Henriksen to play
the part the director had worked with
him on piranha too and the vision he saw
that night was more in line with his
Steely skeletal structure so Cameron
started pitching the Adidas Studios and
he'd often have landscowing wearing full
costume to scare the creatives before
they talked about the film this was
alongside producing partner and future
wife Gail and Hurd who had bought the
rights to film for one dollar Cameron
gave her a writing credit as well so
that it added some authenticity to the
work though he later stated she didn't
actually work on the script although the
studio is all loved it he kept hitting
roadblocks due to some of the
stipulations he had because of his
horrendous experience on Piranha 2 he
wanted full creative control as well as
the job of directing and casting the
movie he eventually managed to get the
former but the studio said he had to
have a named star on the role in order
for them to go ahead with it several
names were put forward apparently also
including O.J Simpson though Cameron has
gone on to deny this but that Dark Horse
did do a comic cover with his likeness
being used so the rumor is something
that's probably going to keep persisting
either way he went to several lunch
meetings though the plan was to always
have Henriksen in the role Kyle Reese
was the person that he thought he could
get away with using the named actor for
and he went off to meet an up-and-comer
called Arnold Schwarzenegger Blown Away
by him Cameron decided to cast him as
the Terminator instead and we all know
how that turned out in the end now I
couldn't believe this when I seen it but
only it was actually 37 years old when
he made this movie guy looks absolutely
incredible and it's crazy to think that
actually nine years between this and
pumping iron I know he gets a lot of
[__] for doing steroids but this guy
retired from the sport a full decade
before he ever stepped put on this set I
know a couple of bodybuilders and and
they'll tell you how difficult it is to
maintain a physique like this and for
him to be in competition shape for that
long shows it's more than just hitting
the stats guy definitely must have had
an insane work ethic and I think his
performance goes beyond just what could
have been a very thankless role he
prepared a ton in advance for this film
and practiced daily at gun rages so he
could get to the point where he could
fire without blinking we also had
Cameron employing what he called
Guerrilla filmmaking and you do not
having permits a lot of the scenes were
shot on the go and that takes us into
the movie itself and Cameron has
described this as being a tech Noir Tech
Noir is of course detective Noir
shortened and the club we visit later on
in the film has that name too the entire
movie is set in La as well but we begin
in the year 2029 the desolate landscape
shows a dismantle and destroyed World
which is interrupted by the arrival of a
hunter killer in our aliens breakdown we
talked about how Cameron often takes
people from One extreme to the other as
this instantly makes you gripped by
what's happening on the screen that's
the case here too with the silence going
from 0 to 60 as we see a big battle
scene play out now we aren't meant to
know what's happening here but the
imagery makes it clear that Humanity's
been destroyed I love the shot in which
we watch tank treads riding other piles
of human skulls and it instantly lets us
know who the dominant Force here is and
from here we could do a big block of
text that explains what's happened in
this world in order to get behind the
idea why this was so fearing you saying
you have to look at the way the world
was back in the 1980s nuclear war was a
big fear and Cameron actually grew up
around the time of the Cuban Missile
Crisis he stated that he vividly
remembered having the fear that a bomb
could be dropped at any second and this
could destroy him and his entire life
nukes were a major fear at the time with
TV shows like the day after being really
popular just the year before now we
learned that nukes were used to kill
most of humanity and then From the Ashes
the Terminators rose up to wipe out the
rest no one knew would hit them and
Cameron State this fear of an unknown
attacks what kept him up at night how
about this idea of the unknown extends
just beyond the nukes and Terminators
also represent this as well beyond just
bombs dropping at any time we had the
idea that summing from the future could
show about the blue and kill us for
something that may or may not happen
Cameron immediately grounds a situation
in this body of text by also letting us
know that the battle will actually be
Fortier in our present tonight such a
cool way to start the film and we get
the story filled in the further we get
into the movie now turns out that
Humanity actually won the war and in a
last-ditch attempt to change things the
machine sent back a Terminator in order
to kill Sarah Connor Humanity sent
someone back to protector unless we have
this closed loop where the events of the
film lead to the resistance Leader's
creation along with his enemy Skynet
it's all one big a closed loop in which
the battle in the past happens and this
then leads to the war in the future
which causes the battle in the past to
happen it's all time you why me wibbly
wobbly stuff but it's really well
structured and one take recently did a
video in the film that pointed out
something I'd never considered normally
in time travel films the characters are
going back to change things but that
isn't the case when it comes to this
movie Skynet are the ones who want to
alter the past whereas the humans are
the people that want to keep things the
way they are now you probably have
noticed that yourself but this means
that Kyle is well aware that he's going
back to die and he still doesn't try to
change things living in the future you
probably know there's not an older Kyle
Reese walking around and in ensuring his
death the future stays the same there's
obviously a lot of great video essays on
the movie with us being 40 years old so
you know I will be shouting out people
along the way and crediting them for
stuff but definitely check out what the
Terminator is really about by one take
as it's one of the best I've seen on the
film now originally they were gonna
touch upon some of these things and in
some of the only drafts we had plot
points showing the future war and more
of cyberdyne systems Sarah wanted to
convince Kyle that they should destroy
the company which is when we stated that
never happened in his timeline so they
weren't gonna go do it Cameron also
wanted to send two Terminators back with
a second being a liquid metal one
however he quickly realized that the
technology wasn't there yet and both of
these ideas would of course show up in
the second film anyway from here we go
to the title sequence and hear the
iconic soundtrack blasting away in the
background I think that this movie owes
a lot to John Carpenter and it
definitely brings across elements of his
films this includes the synthesized
music The Terminator being like Michael
Myers and we get the police station
scene which Rifts on Assault on Precinct
13. I've always viewed the Terminator as
being like a Sci-Fi slasher and we have
several of the archetypes here playing
in full effect you've got the
Unstoppable killer the final girl and
the Terminator Works more like a mass
murdering machine ripped right out of
one of those movies now after this intro
we pick up in 19 84 to see the arrival
of the Terminator just like the opening
shot with the skulls Cameron expertly
uses this Cena juxtaposed the one we get
with Kyle Reese in order to show who's
the more formidable Force the Terminator
comes in looking ripped as hell like an
ancient Olympian statue carved out of
stone Kyle's cut up or as the Terminator
doesn't have a mark on his body and even
when he stabbed he's completely
unflinching he's slow precise and isn't
shocked as stunned when he appears in
the past now if we jump over to Reese's
entrance it's a lot different he drops
in slams off the ground and it's almost
like he's been dumped there it shows the
Precision of a machine and how they can
make complex calculations even across
time and space humans are well human so
we make mistakes sometimes and mess
things up which could be why Rhys drops
in without any Grace and the Terminator
is a huge bulking machine or as Reese's
slim and wiry leading to them being
almost Polar Opposites the Terminator
coolly walks around surveying the area
where she he crouches down and runs
through it almost step he's hiding and
Afraid oni's got it all hanging out
literally whereas Rhys is sheepish and
keeping a low profile in case he gets
caught the lack of fear in the
Terminators seen in the first people he
encounters as well as Ani attacks them
or as recess to run from the police now
early on we get our first hint the
Terminator as a machine with his eyes
scanning the area and likely mapping it
out now this is the Griffith Observatory
which has become a major location in the
franchise in Terminator resistance we
learned that the Skynet Central core was
located underneath it which is likely
why the terminate was dropped in here
Terminator Salvation also reuse the
location as well and both Kyle recent
Star were living in the Runes of it
anyway the Terminator comes across some
punks most notably played by Bill Paxton
and Brian Thompson don't know who the
other guy is but he lives so there you
go that's your reward now Bill's
character Johnny says [__] you [__]
and this is a line that the Terminator
uses himself later on showing that he'll
likely learned it from here
[__] you [__] also the designation of
the Terminator it is a bit all over the
place as well as in this film it's
referred to as the t101 however come T2
it gets called the T800 so yeah
apologies if I keep calling them
different things throughout the video
but the filmmakers didn't even really
know anyway I love how this kind of
intro starts off as a mystery and now we
have some idea what's going on we're not
100 this is made even better by
re-sasking what day is it the dates well
may Thursday what year
and itches away at us until we find the
answer now another interesting detail we
can catch on Kyle is that his arm has a
barcode on it in the franchise we learn
Humanity was enslaved by the machines
and that they were put to work this
clearly Echoes the Holocaust and I think
it's been brought across to signify this
here you also see there's a police car
in here there's a 2-1-1 in progress of
Bob's Liquor on the corner of 13 Cameron
now big shout outs to Reddit user
healthier 9 for pointing out that this
is another James Cameron with the
Terminator being his third film now both
recent Terminator used similar tactics
with a pair picking up a phone Buck to
track Sarah down Reese rips out the page
so that he can refer to it or as a
Terminator doesn't need to because he's
a computer all the Terminators of course
can make copies of data and their
memories can be played back meaning that
he'll have a complete scan of this and
one thing that you might not notice as
well is how the Terminator looks through
the names whereas Kyle uses one finger
the Terminator he uses two because he's
able to process more information at once
now one of the the best details I
noticed in the entire film happens at
this moment too on the right we can see
the terminator's finger dropping down
and this is so that he can find Sarah
however if we look at what's on the left
then we can see that he's rested on the
name John Connor this is of course the
primary target and though he's not been
born yet it shows the t101 still has him
in the crosshairs I love how he finds
both John and Sarah Connor and I know
this flies by in a second it's such a
cool detail that blew my mind when
watching it now John's of course a
Messianic figure and the initials JC of
course also belong to Jesus Christ
anyway from here we jump over to see a
young Sarah Connor and making her way to
work she's sort of in the same vein as
Laurie Strode from Halloween and
presented almost like a virginal marry
figure who's yet to be tested she works
as a waitress at a restaurant called Big
Jeff's which is of course a play on Big
Boy customers complain she makes
mistakes and even little kids are
dropping ice cream in her Pockets I love
how we're also made to think about the
future here as well with a friend saying
look her this way in 100 years who's
gonna care everyone's gonna cab me
because they keep sending Terminators
back constantly you're trying to kill
her and from here we could do a scene
that always makes me chuckle I don't
know if it's intentional or not but only
asking for plasma rifles at a gun store
always cracks me up phased plasma rifle
in the 40 watt range hey just what you
see pal
the uzi nine millimeter
in the counter and look I know I'm not
American yet but I just always imagine
that anytime someone buys a gun that
this moment crosses the shopkeeper's
Mind sort of like how whenever you get
into the sea you think it's yours and
whenever you're on a long road you think
of Final Destination too or Final
Destination if you're on a plane or
Final Destination 3 if you're on a
roller I think that's the roller coaster
one anyway we see that a laser sight is
added to the handgun which wasn't
actually that easy to get their hands on
this was actually something that they
had to make and mask for the movie in
order to make it seem like it was legit
what they did is that they added a laser
on top and then ran a wire down on his
glove which went up his sleeve and then
down the back to a power supply now
we've been talking about opposites a lot
in the breakdown and we see another one
demonstrated in Reese across town who
watches he has to hide and create a
sworn off shotgun which has a bit of
string tie to it in order to keep it
secure in a nice continuity detail we
see in the club later on that this bit
of strings hanging off the end of it
after he's had to yank it out his coat
anyway both of them continue their
search for Sarah and we see a toy truck
in the street which then gets run over
in a great bit of foreshadowing this is
actually a model of the truck that
Terminator hits at the end of the film
and that little toy gets revenge for
getting run over the Terminator of
course gets run over and he also ends up
driving it as well which leads to it
being destroyed much like how it does
yeah there's also a young girl riding
around on a tricycle and during the
truck scene the Terminator rides a
motorbike
now he watches the Terminator walks up
to the first Sarah Connor's house now we
can see a dog starts to bark at him as
we learn later these are used in the
future to detect Terminators and there's
some stationed at the base sniffing
those who go in at roughly the one hour
10 Mark we see Reese arriving and he
puts his hand in one of the dog's noses
to show he's not a machine this clearly
became a habit as we even see him doing
it when he gets to the 80s could have
the one hour 15 Mark and we watches him
and Sarah arrive at the motel tell which
is when he walks over the dog and lets
it sniff his hand anyway back with the
Terminator we see as he goes and hits up
the first Sarah Connor the t101 or T800
is just working down the list in the
phone book because that's the most
logical thing that a computer would do
baristo he has played things differently
and he stopped on the bottom name
because he had a better idea of who she
was now as the Terminator breaks in the
door we see things switch to slow motion
which is a technique Cameron also used
when he murders Ginger this perfectly
plays off to add some tension later on
and we see everything slowed down when
the Terminators at the club just when
the machine gets Sarah in his sight
everything slows down again and though
it's not a crazy detail it shows how
small Cameron is when it comes to
repeating techniques to add tension now
they were actually going to do something
here where he'd cut open her leg and
this was because he was looking for
metallic pins Skynet apparently had
information that she'd had an operation
on it at one point and they then use
this to identify the real one although
the movie would with her breaking a leg
at the factory and then she'd have to go
on to get the operation that would then
cause it Elemento this are still left in
the movie and at the end we see that she
badly damages her leg during the factory
scene
I think the pen thing shows that this
was always meant to be and that it being
there for the machines to learn shows
that they caused it in the past lots of
time you want me wibbly wobbly stuff and
we joined Reese's parked up outside a
construction site the lights on the
truck blind him a bit and this
transitions perfectly into the future
War the trades don't seem out of place
but when we pan down we see there once
more on top of skulls now the battle
shows how bleaked that the future is and
how important Reese's mission is to make
sure they win go back to Sarah's home
where she and her mate Ginger are
getting ready for their date Sarah is
wearing a Jetsons t-shirt and this is of
course about a family that live far in
the future but robots aren't their
slaves there looking at you Rosie get
back to work now after they get the
biggest perms possible we get a little
vocal Cameo by James Cameron canceling
his and Sarah's date hi Sarah Dan morske
Uh something's come up and it looks like
I won't be able to make it tonight so I
just can't get out of it look I'm really
sorry I'll make it up to you call you in
a day or so okay sorry bye in a weird
twist of fate camera would actually end
up marrying Linda Hamilton and he was
also married to Gail and Hood as well
man also yeah man also married the
daughter from Titanic so you better
watch out Zoe Saldana lad's Coming For
You Anyway Sarah heads up by herself
which is when the Terminator attacks
after hearing there's someone out there
killing people with her name she decides
to head to a club which is where she
notices that Reese is following her huge
it adds to Rebecca for doing a video
essay on just this scene and he talked
about how elements are used to
foreshadow the future we have metallic
fences sheets lining the wall and light
shining down similar to the hunter
killer beams the song in the background
is about a photograph which Rhys has in
the future and this is to show him what
Sarah looks like the chairs and tables
are made of metal too and we also have a
doorman wearing a skeleton on his
T-shirt genuinely cannot recommend the
guy highly enough he's he's influenced
his channel so much and he's done a much
deeper that 11 minute breakdown on just
as seeing that I'd definitely recommend
you go and watch now across town he
watches the Terminator arrives at
Sarah's home this moment reminded me a
lot of the boyfriend and girlfriends
seen from Halloween with the villain
easily handling the man before Ginger
now the phone rings and we see how
precise the machine is when he whips
around and points his gun at it the
laser rests steadily on the telephone
without moving and this is to cement how
accurate the Terminators are we also get
a nice little meta joke with the answer
machine saying hi there
you're talking to
a mission that's me or Sarah will get
back to you wait for the beep the Sarah
doesn't realize but she's actually
talking to a machine when she's leaving
the voicemail and this lets the
Terminator know exactly where she is
bones are what gives Sarah away twice in
the movie and later on we watch as she
calls her mother from the motel [__]
I'll tell you get gets a blood boiling
just thinking about it however Cameron
wanted to play on some of the fears at
the time and there was a lot of
publicity around wiretapping people
listening into phone calls and privacy
being breached by Foreign entities
Watergate happened about a decade before
and this themes become even more
relevant with the internet and apps
collecting your data now the t101 or the
T800 arrives at the club and it all goes
down with them shining the laser
directly at Sarah's head we get this
hitting us too and this screen goes red
somewhat foreshadowing the red eyes of
the Terminator we see later on Reese
manages to knock him down and in a nice
bit of sound design you can actually
hear his shotgun blast hitting against
the terminator's metallic skeleton
you also get this iconic line
come with me if you want to live with
your Terminator uses in T2 to show that
she can trust him now the chasing needs
to Reese blowing up a car which the
Terminator then jumps back through this
actually burns the character's eyebrows
off and it singes the front of his head
to make him look even more menacing as
he gets off the ground we see his jacket
as smell coming off of it and this was
achieved with Cameron pouring acid onto
it Oni said that a [__] act and has
mentioned several times that his skin
was cooking during this in the car we
watch as he shows his ability to mimic
people which he later uses to pretend to
be Sarah's mother
1l19 westbound an Olympic approaching
overlooking
I love you too sweetheart
now after Carl explain to Sarah what's
happening the Terminator arrives and the
chase continues across La I think right
and it's nitpicking yet but an issue
that I have with this film is that the
Terminator crashes the car at this point
and then runs off just cause the police
show up we see him later turn up to the
station and take everyone out and I
never really got why the guy had to run
away at this point at the police station
we get a little breather and we get to
meet franchise Mainstay Dr Silverman now
one pony says he could make an entire
career out of this thing now we've seen
T2 how he's managed to do this also at
the Terminator goes after repair itself
which yeah I guess could explain why he
darts off on the car man gets blown in
half later on and keeps going though so
let's stop with the nitpicks now from
here we get the eye removal scene and
you might notice that when Arnie grabs
the scalpel that the blade is there but
when he puts it to his eyes it's in fact
missing done for safety reasons they
would of course use CGI if this was done
today a little plastic head puts on his
sunglasses to cover the wound and we
watch as he heads out now donning a new
costume this is where the iconic look
really comes from and we get what is one
of the most famous movie lines of all
time
I'll be back even though you can see the
guy's eye isn't missing there's just
something about this that really
captures what makes the Terminator
special I love how the Terminator is
saying what he thinks a human would and
not draw suspicion but there's also
something quite robotic about it Ani
famously argued with Cameron said about
it because to his Austrian ears it
didn't sound correct Cameron fired back
by saying I don't tell you how to act so
don't tell me how to write and that was
that now as this is going on we see that
Sarah is being comforted by the cops
with us getting the line it'll be
perfectly safe
I got 30 cops in this building huge
announce to claudits and Reddit for
pointing out that if you count the cops
at the Terminator kills then you get 30
in total some of the deaths happen off
screen but going by how many bits of buy
there is it totals out at that they also
pointed out that the numbers on the hood
along the side are also digits from the
assembly code for the Apple II in the
terminator's vision things going slow-mo
and this could be because it's
processing power makes things seem
slower either way the massacre here
helps to heighten how much of a threat
this guy is normally in horror movies
there's a sense of safety when the
police appear because you know they have
weapons in training there's been a
number of films that have ended with the
heroes making it to safety just by
reaching the police but the Terminator
shows that even these are on a match for
him now just before Lance henriksen's
character is shot and killed we can see
a bulletin board with a missing poster
on it unfortunately the child we see
here isn't a prop and this the real life
missing case of Kevin Collins Kevin was
one of the first people on a milk carton
and sadly Still Remains missing to this
day he was on his way home from
basketball practice which he'd normally
leave alongside his brother however he
was homesick that day so couldn't travel
back and Witnesses reported seeing Kevin
at the bus stop talking to a tall blonde
man sadly he was never seen again and
decades later someone used his ID to try
and get a passport the person filing the
paperwork noticed the name and called
the police and a cadaver dog also
seemingly inert what were thought to be
his remains this was in an abandoned
building but in the end this was
revealed to be just in animals now the
search still goes on and if you know the
story that's an eerie layer of sadness
to this whole scene either way Sarah and
Rhys make it out and we hear of the
radio how there's a massive Manhunt for
the
terminatory is
five southern counties are engaged in a
massive Manhunt for 100. we then get her
patching up his wounds which is when he
talks about Jon
die for John Connor
at least now I know what to name him
this is a great little line in hindsight
and it shows the constant leap of time
with Kyle telling her what his name is
in the future so that she can name him
in the past Kyle also talks about how
Jon never mentions his father and I
think that this is done for a couple of
reasons not only does he not want Carl
knowing that much but I think it'd also
be difficult to discuss his death with
him when he's well aware he's sending
him to it it's weird to think that Jon
would have had a relationship with both
his parents but it would be during a
time when neither were around to meet
each other now he hit the point in the
typical hero's journey where Sarah
rejects the call but she's inspired by a
speech of Curry that Jon told Kyle in
the future this is when we get Risa
explaining what his world's like and we
see a repeat of the opening shot with us
watching The Wall play out using rear
projection Cameron's able to give the
idea that this is a massive Wasteland
inside we watch his re-seize the
downtrodden and beaten and again had an
unintentional laugh with this but I
always find it funny that there's people
just sat watching a burning fire on TV
just just don't know what they're doing
but you know what I suppose it's better
than watching this anyway a terminated
by sin at this point and this character
is played by bodybuilder Franco Columbu
like Arnie Colombo was a Mr Olympia
winner and he was also a close friend of
Arnie from the circuits anyway we wake
up to find Sarah asleep in Kyle's arms
what's wrong mate my story of the future
boring you never never forgive you for
ringing your mum what the [__] were you
thinking now
I don't know if you guys have ever
watched hunted yet but every every year
they have some [__] on and they make it
clear them don't call anyone or use your
phone and there's always someone here
there's always someone who calls home
and that's what gets them caught now
whenever that happens I inevitably think
of this scene and I tell you the blood's
bloody boiling just thinking about it
now before that though we have to watch
the Terminator tracking her down and we
get some really interesting details on
his skin you can actually catch flies
sitting on his cheeks and this is
because the flash over the endoskeleton
has started to rotten Fester the
custodian with the hairiest shallows
I've ever seen also knocks at the door
and if you listen closely you can hear
he actually knocks the theme tune
thank you
[Music]
quite a funny little detail and we
watched Sarah and Carl enter the motel
with a truck they let us deal sat up in
the car park at Sarah's mothers we see
that she's been murdered and the doors
being kicked and then blasted similar to
how The Terminator operates now you
millenniums might not know this but back
in the day you could dial a number and
this instantly called back the person
who just called you this is how the
Terminator tracks her down and and
seeing him type out that number it took
me back now the pair then make love to
one of the most romantic reworkings of a
theme ever because like
foreign after the scene we see a big
change in Kyle and the next scene in the
motel is the only time the character
actually smiles in the movie Reddit use
a latchkey TV also pointed out that this
is probably the only time that the
characters ever had a shower in his life
which is why he's now looking sharp I
also believe that from this point
onwards that Sarah refers to him as Kyle
or as previously she just called him
Rhys other piece is interrupted by the
dog barking and they realize they have
to run as the Terminator closes in a big
car chase ensues with a Terminator
getting hit and we actually see his leg
getting damaged as he travels under the
truck added taking other driver we get a
shot of his leg limping along and the
character continues to walk with this
for the rest of the film destroying the
truck we watch as the Terminator goes
down in flames and I love how he seems
stumble out the fire and then he starts
to melt now back when this was released
it wasn't a massive cliche to have the
villain come back for the final scene
and that whole fire thing it does seem
like a conclusive ending this is why it
hit so hard and I think that this scene
still works today with the Terminator
rising out of the Flames similar to what
Cameron saw in his dreams though it's
stop-motion and people might think the
effects look a bit wonky I think they
actually work really well with the tone
of the film there's this otherworldly
feeling to it and Stan Winston perfectly
brings the limping robot to life tarkens
back to movies like Clash of the Titans
and seeing the Unstoppable structure
strut along feels very impactful now in
the factory we do get a bit of
foreshadowing when Sarah carries Kyle
she goes to climb up a ledge and
accidentally presses a button which sets
the crusher off this is the same button
Sarah presses to kill the machine later
on which nicely sets up how she knows
that it will work after Reese goes out
in a blaze of glory we see just how
Unstoppable the machine truly is this
thing's been stabbed shot run over
burned and blown up and it still keeps
coming it would have course gone to
inspire other horror creatures like Mr
Rex and the Nemesis but this unwavering
machine was the first to do it crawling
over Reese's corpse it then starts to
creep after her but Sarah manages to
finally take it out
leaving behind his arm this then allows
for cyberdyne systems to go and create
the Terminator so you have two things
being quote unquote birthed in this
movie with the Terminators very much
creating themselves and then the thing
that will destroy them by pushing Sarah
and Kyle together from here we catch
Sarah on the road with a dog in the back
and a gun at her waist driving down the
long road to the upcoming storm she gets
the photo taken that Reese will later
carry and everything in the end ties up
really nicely although it does have this
Bittersweet side to it and I think that
this movie might have one of the best
endings of all time it's symbolic on a
number of different levels as though we
know that the Terminator is being
stopped the feature is still coming
kinda has an opposite ending to what the
film has with this very much being about
how the feature is set in stone whereas
at that goes against it here though we
have the storm off in the distance which
Sarah knows she's unable to divert from
that is Forever on the horizon but like
the Terminator she's unwavering from her
goals she's heading towards it and the
road leading straight to it is a
forward-facing line much like the time
stream itself which continues to travel
in One Direction the other clouds close
in Sarah's heading there with her dog
and unborn son they'll now begin the
training for what's coming around the
corner now from here we go to the
credits and get one that says
acknowledgment to the works of Holland
Ellison this is a bit of a sore point
for Cameron as Alison threatened to see
Orion for copyright infringement when
the movie was released claiming it was
based on his Outer Limits episode
Soldier this saw two people from the
future traveling back in time to battle
it out in the past I have watched the
episode another awesome minor things
like that but I don't think there's any
real similarities Beyond it however
Orion was scared of what could happen
and Cameron was told that if he didn't
agree to credit Ellison then he'd have
to pay the damages thus they settled
with Cameron saying that he had no
choice but to agree even though he says
he didn't steal from the story now this
lawsuit was all done in 1986 and thus
every copy of the film since then has
come with this disclaimer at the end we
see let me know below what you think on
the situation and that just so happens
to wrap up the movie and what a bloody
movie it was I mean this is to me this
is still one of the best films ever made
and I hope that going back through it
like this has helped you to spot some
things that you might not have noticed
before as promised we will be back with
our Terminator 2 breakdown so make sure
you stay locked to the channel so you
don't miss out hopefully you've enjoyed
this and if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
Brighton of robocult which will be
linked on screen now without the way
I've been Paul you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
and I'll be back I'll be back for
Terminator 2
I'll be back